[Music]
welcome back to the Julian podcast still
in our house haven't left this week's
episode is brought to you by the
wonderful texture guys you want to read
magazines but you don't want to deal
with the clunky old
physical burden of having magazines go
to texture it makes all of the
magazine's you want to read right at
your fingertips
okay right now you can spare your free
trial by going to texture comm /tao to
Julian and check it out it's really
great also brought to you by Squarespace
as if you're looking to build a website
Squarespace makes it very easy to build
a beautiful seamless wonderful
functional website 24/7 customer support
all sorts of different options and
layouts for you to choose from
way to customize your website it's very
awesome right now you get 10% off your
first purchase or a domain by going to
Squarespace comm slash Jenna Julian or
click the link in the description and
now we are rough morning this morning so
we're trying to like do something to
cheer ourselves up I feel like right
yeah today was a fun day peach you're
gonna sit down you're not gonna purr
like a cat cuz we're podcasting she's on
my desk sit sit dog keyboarding ruin
everything
mm-hmm yeah I got sort of sick this
morning so we were kind of void of our
of our Sunday I think it was the most
pain I've ever seen you in since I've
known you
mm-hmm I would say those who's up there
Julian might have eaten some gluten
yesterday so yeah pretty terrible for
those they don't know I've seen the
activities I'm not just like against
gluten but yeah sometimes my reactions
are worse than other times and today
might have been like possibly my worst
reaction I've ever had yeah so not a fun
day you had to turn on Drake and Josh at
one point so that you could relax a
little yeah what sucked is that I
couldn't even really lay down yeah like
it woke me up cuz I couldn't sleep so
like 8:00 a.m. when you're sick and you
can't even like lay down
it's pretty terrible yeah go to sleep
but we knew the Cure all along we'll
just take a nice little sip of snake oil
and how are you so now here we are we're
playing snake oil the game where we have
to sell ridiculous things made up to
each other who are taking on the roles
of fictional professions mm-hmm we hate
that's not yours trying to eat peach Hey
go now
she's so naughty right now um the first
time that we did this this was just like
someone sent us this game right mm-hmm I
don't remember
I think someone sent it to us yeah and
so like we like to try and play games
and stuff we never know what's gonna be
like fun or funny or whatever but like I
feel like this one went a lot better
than we had anticipated yeah because
you're incredible at selling absolute
garbage what can I say I'm a man of very
odd and useless talents like the last
shirt that you sold me was out of
control you needed the water okay as far
as I know our company is not received an
invoice your church owes us money he
installed the big umbrella oh you money
we installed the only prototype it's
completely dysfunctional at this point
but it's still installed we left our
venmo
email on there we don't know what
happened so for those who haven't seen
the first episode feel free to check it
out it's just the snake-oil podcast it's
I don't know 20 podcasts ago or
something like that well we need some
good cheer in them yeah so the way the
game works just to kind of go through it
one person will be selling and one
person will be buying the person who is
buying takes on one of these cards which
is a fake profession so they have ninja
or they have geek so random sort of
professions are people that are buying
that way salesmen tailors their sales
pitch to that specific person
the salesman takes two random word cards
combines the words and that's the item
that they are selling it's pretty much
it there supposed to be a time limit but
we're just like no [ __ ]
yeah like for kids and it's supposed to
be fast we're better than kids kids
probably suck at this - um the kids -
yeah I'm gonna use that in one of my
pitches okay okay I need you to pick a
profession card because I'm ready to
sell I'm ready to sell you got to be
ready to buy just ready for the [ __ ]
that's coming my way all right I'm a
teacher I don't remember all the ones
that we did last time so forgive us we
have some double professions they don't
give you a lot of these cards god I have
the right to decline your sales pitch
and say no as a person involved in the
education system you know how important
presentation is you're after all you are
giving presentations to your students
every day I am in some way or another if
you look the part you are the part so
you must look like a professional in
front of these students you can't show
up at work like a slob stop it I need to
listen about how you need a dress okay I
mean we have a dress code but you can't
go in wearing all your all your bling
you can't just dress up yourself with
jewelry and night and nice things your
students will steal from you they will
take it because it is not equipped for
work it is jewelry that they know is
worth a lot and they would rather steal
your [ __ ] than study for a stupid test
no offense but offense you cannot wear a
fancy jewelry to class or it will be
stolen by your tiny kids what you need
is something suited for the job that
shows that you're a professional that
shows that you look good and you're
ready to go but will not cause a
distraction
you need a work bracelet a bracelet only
from work you will not touch this on any
Saturday or Sunday it is forbidden by us
and our company we work with the US
government and we will find you if you
wear this on the weekend but during the
week it is part of your work attire
during the week you don't get to have it
we are eliminating those people from our
market they do not get to have this
bracelet is an exclusive very exclusive
very important it will keep you safe how
do you tell what a work bracelet is if
you have to ask that question you're
already too late
you don't have one we're selling them
for one day only everyone who gets them
today tomorrow we're selling them
tomorrow if you don't buy yours tomorrow
you will have to work every job forever
without a Bork bracelet and you'll have
to get every all of your [ __ ] stolen by
kids it has GPS installed in it so if
you ever forget where your school is and
you have a mental breakdown because your
kids are torturing you every day in
class your GPS on your work bracelet
will guide you right to your classroom
right to your classroom so with a
built-in alarm clock - you cannot
oversleep class if you're the teacher
what kind of precedent does that set
this is something you cannot go on as a
teacher without you understand that
right the chalkboard what's it gonna do
when you're out of chalk Oh gross chalk
it spits out chalk out of the workplace
that forms another cube I have a
question I'll take your question are you
selling this to me as an alternative to
expensive Apple Saturday and Sunday are
for expensive jewelry Monday through
Friday work bracelet only so in fact we
know when you're wearing it when you're
not it doesn't you have to wear it you
already bought it you can't use anymore
just telling you what's going on now
notified that you took it off and you're
not wearing it at work like a legal
prison why would I why would I buy a
thousand years ago you agreed to buy
this I was born years ago years ago
we've been notified we are here to tell
you that you need to put it back on or
you have to come with us are you
we are the work government excuse me we
come from the DMV it has Auto assist
when you drive as well this is made by
the DMV please buy a bracelet front last
episode it was like candy belts we are
cops and the umbrella water we are Brita
so now you're a work bracelet we are the
DMV so should buy it but we are the DMV
so this is a DMV I'm not even supposed
to be talking to you you don't have an
appointment today
yes okay so it's spits chalk that sounds
sort of it's chalk for my profession
spits chalk so when you run out of chalk
for your chalkboard if you still use the
chalkboard you will now have more chalk
also it has GPS tracking so if you have
a mental breakdown it'll tell you where
your school is there only links to your
school that's the only function on the
GPS so not like my house family member
it's like a hub on the work bracelet
that's programmed for your work nothing
else okay
it it charges through a blood flow the
Sun is not it takes your blood No takes
your blood and it powers itself what
blood type are you
I don't know we know already it's been
powered by your blood type it only works
with your blood type I don't want this
product I don't want it
well think of it like this how many on
it like give me a number between like
twenty to twenty seven about how many
nice pieces Julie used to have been
stolen from your kids is I know it's
somewhere little probably a little high
end 26 25 so let's just call it 25 that
will become none you'll have the
workplace that they're gonna look at
that and be so intimidated that they're
gonna not even want to piss you off and
go to detention because in detention the
work bracelet shifts into a fighting
bracelet
we I'm gonna fight my kids so only when
they're only when they're really really
bad oh you saw me get fired no work
bracelet hides old evidence we are with
the DMV will you please buy a bracelet
six dollars you have to buy it I don't
want it well if you don't buy it
then who are we gonna get sell this to
we're gonna go out of business right now
we need you to buy our bracelet I don't
want it it doesn't sound functional
dangerous what are we doing our company
now everything on you buying it I don't
know my dad I mean take my hand it'll be
around your wrist in no time sweetheart
you know it's also made of platinum
tinfoil it's $6 a minute that's nothing
just live minutes yes congratulations
sir thank you for making that deal with
me I don't want it but like it was a
really good sales pitch I think I think
you will absolutely regret this moment
it's just a matter of time of when I see
I'm making this deal right now but I'm
gonna return it we have a no return
policy
strict the moment you touch it you are
responsible for our our whole company's
operations so now we can literally go to
you for money now thank you for buying
your present that'll be shipped in 2019
no you have to pace all right now know
what minute is it it's
it's the six minute of the hour you have
to pay it was pretty strong are you
proud of yourself
all I'm here to do is make sales cashing
checks and snapping necks is what they
say at the DMV I don't understand it I'm
thinking I'm picking a new I'm a spy oh
yeah you picked a man it's not even good
all right
so Julian yes you're out there in the
world we're just gonna assume that
you're on some very important mission
Sam three at the moment we don't we
don't know who you're spying for or who
you're spying on but guess what what
whatever country you are a spy for
you're a citizen just as much as anybody
else that is true have rights and you
know your jobs really stressful and like
really important sometimes you're in
some dangerous situations I wake up
screaming every night weeks turn into
months and you know my thirties weeks
turn into months sometimes you don't
know where you are your job takes you
all over the gloves room and you have
endless gadgets and technology
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
with you shoes they contain a small tiny
knife in them you will always be taxes
on time it's a single analog clock that
sits or goes with you wherever you are
it just says tax time is it giving me an
indicator when I'm gonna be audited or
when I have to submit when you need to
submit tax isn't that how big is it it's
pretty small like like this big I've
been spending recklessly I have a couple
questions what but if I'm traveling all
over the place
mm-hmm why would you give me an analogue
clock that I have to keep resetting
every single goddamn time I travel God
everything's digital but you know it
can't be hacked
I assume you're very worried about all
of your belongings getting hammered six
iPhones all of them have been hacked
exactly nobody can hack an analog clock
nobody that is true true no enemies all
over the world people want to kill you
have a question nose listen people want
to hack your tax clock so that you get
audited by your own government your own
government takes you out if it's an
analog clock they can't get you they
can't hack you you will always pay your
taxes on if one of the people that I am
hired to spy on as a professional spy is
the IRS would this be considered a
conflict of interests no okay
and how what type of batteries does it
take to double A's two doublea's for an
analog clock okay one double-a know it
takes the say it takes the disk the flat
one that you don't replace for like ten
years
okay it takes the flat one you don't
have to replace I didn't think you're
gonna say it takes the flat one you know
it suppose for ten years that's an
interesting point that's it do we have a
deal how much is it
what is the payment schedule $19.99
there is no payment schedule use one
one-time payment that's $20 what's a
return policy you can return it anytime
you want but you have the technology how
does it know when tax time is you said
it so it's just the clock yeah get away
from me I'm a spy no I'm gonna be I'm
gonna be seen it tells you it's tax time
does it say tax time yeah and what
language I only speak Czechoslovakian no
that's not true I haven't had this
conversation you're speaking to me in
English
you are not having a conversation with
me who am I talking to I'm not familiar
with this do we have a deal you tax them
I like tax clock they like tax clock it
would be an interesting twist if tax
clock was actually made by the IRS to
fool people into doing it too late
all right I'm gonna put this over here
cuz you're to use Prius anyway all right
I'm gonna take a new profession all
right hmm all right I'm a rock star okay
okay I don't know this one seems pretty
strong though right here Tyree can I
read you one of these yeah go for it
okay
you are successful mm-hmm you're turning
around the United States and other
countries you're turning around the
world doing shows what is the aim of
your band flat white no coconut milk
flat whites the sound foam renegade the
the poker brigade poker brigades that's
the right poker what's your name what's
name you've been no I forgot you are a
very good band you sold out your shows
mm-hmm but when you're at these concerts
and you get tired mm-hmm you can't just
walk offstage
if you're on stage performing you cannot
turn around and walk away otherwise
people get bummed out that's true they
do at a concert they're hammered they
don't even remember how they got there
but if they see you turn around and
slipper off they are sad and then you
have sad hands sad people on your hands
literally and figuratively
some of them put themselves on your
hands so tiny not good for anyone no you
go you go back to your bus tour bus
driver says hey chief how did you show
go and you say it was bad I walked
offstage like a sad sack and everyone
left and you might not have a job
tomorrow mr. driver - by the way where's
my [ __ ] lunch you're rude to your
driver I don't know that's your problem
no I I don't understand why you and your
driver have beep all he does is Drive
you around we don't you know that that's
not an option you can't just turn around
and walk away okay but you need to leave
sometimes you need a get off stage for
your mental health it is crazy
it's too loud there's a lot of people
showing you stuff from the flashing you
from the ground and your I don't want to
see that you need to get out of there
fast nobody's gonna understand why
you're leaving which the reality is that
you're really sad and you don't want to
be performing but it looks like you're
having a good time
grenade sucks your socks up and leave
the concert in the most incredible
fashion no one knows what happened your
god no meanwhile you're flying through
the air tears streaming down your face
your life but nobody knows you're
summing up the grenade Sox blasted you
have no hundred feet
minimum every flight now your feet are
perfectly safe because the inside the
socks are made from ballistic
bulletproof vests for socks for feet
custom fitted to your feet Jeff you have
a size eight it only works if you have a
size eight the other size eight yes you
do this could work we only sell this in
size eight for women but it does mean it
doesn't mean you need to walk around in
socks literally everywhere you go in no
shoes why no absolutely no deal I do not
it comes with a parachute they deploy
when you get to your pee kind of 5,000
feet in there yeah I don't I don't want
to do that but the explosion that blasts
you off yeah so explosive and crazy that
you black out so you don't even remember
it no what about the pods I don't think
they got this show of their life it has
a blast containment technology that when
it blasts off it only hurts the people
that are stupid if you have stupid
people who are heckling you know you say
and then you press the button no it's
like writing your you put it in your
belly button no it's a little round knob
no you just stick it up in there and
then if you're having a good concert be
like I'm tired I want to go netball and
if you blast off 4000 miles into the air
you touch the moon and you float back no
congratulations you just made the
Billboard top 10 with that I exit not
shaking your hand
no no deal we are the army come be
another me
we have grenades no I do not want
grenade socks please no there's smoke
grenade socks no it's fake no you don't
actually explode it just deploys smoke
so you can walk around with smoke around
your feet okay
that's a cool product and then it
explodes there you go 5,000 feet in
there and they got the concert of their
lifetime no if you sold them to me as
socks that had grinny like smoke
grenades in them okay you could walk
around like that that's cool okay so our
our main product is grenade socks but
we're working on a prototype that is
smoke grenade socks
I'd buy smoke grenade stuff okay in the
meantime you'll wear the grenade socks
do we have a deal no just once just once
just thank you sir congratulations on
all your successes also this requires
you to give me and my kids free concert
tickets for your entire entire life to
any culture that's not even yours you
need a biased concert tickets to our
favorite bands that are not you you need
to buy them no we don't like you we want
to see other concerts but you need to
buy them for us Congrats thank you for
that deal that's partly the stipulation
and I get 2% of every no pizza you read
no no are you sure yes well you already
took my hand though you don't get to
make other clauses in our agreement oh
you you signed it earlier
no we shook hands no you signed it
remember that sign-up sheet oh hi name
an email for more information about that
lemonade's then that was actually the
contract we got you yeah gotcha also and
now this is my dog again aren't you
comfort him he looks a little stressed
out there's another part of this sales
pitch there's another part of the sales
pitch
we already you can only find some of the
information about this product online on
the on the grenade Sox website which is
hosted by Squarespace squarespace.com
has all your website building needs and
if you want to build a company that's
titled grenade Sox I'm not [ __ ]
stopping you neither and Squarespace
they're gonna help you to have really
awesome beautiful templates it makes it
incredibly easy to build a website
that's something that is so intimidating
to think about building a website all
the different house how to's of coding
and this and that they make it easy all
right I personally have a website with
Squarespace I have the whop circle
website is a Squarespace hosted one and
it is wonderful and we love it and we're
actually doing a lot more to it lately
now that we've had time to work on it
and square saves me makes it easy one of
the things that I can say from
Squarespace is when they say 24/7
customer support they mean 24/7 customer
support when you're working on your
website at internet hours which if you
don't know what that is it's when you're
up in the middle of the night because
the Internet allows you to work all
hours like us they have support then for
you which is so important you don't have
to wait until 8:00 a.m. to call some
hotline and get put on hold
no Squarespace has you covered that's my
favorite part Squarespace right now you
get 10% off ok you can make your 2018
awesome by building that website you've
always wanted to build but you didn't
know how go to Squarespace comm slash
Jenna Julian get 10% off your first
purchase or domain and check it out give
it a shot see how you like it ask all
the questions you need that's what
they're there for
Thank You Squarespace and guys if you
you know walk past the magazine stance
and you're seeing headlines lately they
here like I really actually want to
watch you know see what that magazine is
about to read these articles even if
it's like nonsense stuff that you just
want to read about well when you're
going on a plane you don't have to buy a
magazine you don't have to buy I mean
what do you do when you're done reading
it what a waste that is who's gonna just
buy a magazine and then throw it I mean
that's so stupid we're in 2018 people
get texture texture y'all has tons and
tons of magazines at your fingertips on
your device on your smartphone on your
tablet on your excuse me computers over
200
options of different magazines sorry I'm
burping because I'm so excited about
texture right now you can try texture
for free there's really no risk involved
cast time ESPN
Men's Fitness Marie Claire billboard
reek lair
Oprah voted wine the magazine about
Oprah I mean come on
about Oprah's like no it isn't no it's
not every week it has a different story
about our childhood no that's a whole
magnet it's not true that is not true it
is her networks magazine it's about
different things other than just Oprah
although if it was just about over I
would personally try texture just to
read it anyway go to texture calm / you
know Julian guys start for free today
literally just no no risk of all just
try it for free click the link in the
description see how you like it and uh
like do it it's really cool so thank you
sponsors alright you got a pick a
profession here all right cowboy wait
didn't we have that one lesson I don't
I'm a nurse no I'm a nurse I'm changing
this some of these are like so yeah you
can change them if you need okay [ __ ] I
am a nurse I know you're a nurse so
Julian dr. Julian mm-hmm no no no you're
a nurse nurse Julian thank you uh you
work in a hospital right yes long hours
and we all hear stories from nurses and
people that work in hospitals sometimes
things get a little dicey in there
people coming in faking injuries so they
can try and get prescription drugs
sometimes people have just been in
violent situations kind of dangerous I
got punched in the elbow last week for
no reason
yes I don't care that you
and you wear scrubs all the time right
like they're all outfit yeah the pants
the shirt yeah sometimes don't you just
want to feel a little more feminine or
something I feel way too masculine all
the time just a nice little feminine
energy I need family
yeah surrounded by men all the time I
feel you and you want to protect
yourself right go in your bed yes I want
to protect myself go peach go go away I
want to protect myself at work at work
in otherwise yeah yeah everywhere I need
help it's got a nice you push it on the
skirt part and out pops a bullet from
your chest right here in case you have
in a very dangerous situation and you
need to shoot a gun this feels all
violent but for some people I go through
a metal detector to get into work every
day how is this not gonna set it off it
is I'm going to get fired yeah I have it
in my size mm I'm a 14 yes well I mean
the purpose of the gun dress is like
where we're trying to get you fired
basically from your job at the hospital
so that you can come work as a nurse in
the army or you can dress feminine for
the first time I can wear a dress in the
army yes is it the u.s. army or is it a
third party army third party are what
are you fighting whoever pays us the
most so what gets to decide who we fight
we're a privately owned sector of the US
Army not really
it's like Blackwater are you an
assassination team sort of am i am i
under arrest we want nurse
this is our squad okay are you just here
to bother me because I have medical
knowledge yes do I actually get toward
the dress yes does it actually fire
weapon yes dude where does the Gunpowder
stored in the buttons in the breasts
breasts the breast comes comes in the
dress yeah I've always wanted breasts
how do I know what I need to reload it's
loaded
sounds like a physical problems you
think it might be impossible but it's
not they're all stored in the skirt this
issue real bullets yes wait is it a
skirt or a dress it's a dress and the
skirt of the dress it's like a petticoat
except it's filled with ammo how much
does it weigh a lot like a [ __ ] ton
which means you need to be in great
shape by waving the gun dress it's a
workout tool no it's too dangerous for
that how much is it free if you join our
army what does the contract say how much
time do I have to spend in the army of
assassinating people for money until you
start getting slow and not good at your
job then we'll fight you
sounds like a prison it is know that we
need in you medical expertise in our gun
dress why are their snipers surrounding
me you know um no but also why are their
snipers surrounding me we don't know
them come on nice can I go home yes you
can thank you for the gun dress it's
pretty dank right what color is that I
never asked purple [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
hate purple would you like a different
colors yes what color white okay you
can't make it my way okay you can have a
white done dress canopy a wedding dress
sure can have the thing on top that goes
down what is that home a veil bill I'm
sure there's lots of people that would
like to have a gun dress on their
wedding day okay well now I have one how
much was it it's free yeah as long as
you join our privately-owned army sounds
like I'm gonna get arrested with
in our or for profit oh that's what we
owe that's what you always say yeah
we're we're a bad company it's [ __ ] up
am ia bad person now privately owned
like militaries do exist though that's
the most [ __ ] up part and this is why
we played this game today we wanted to
raise awareness for take a profession
and I'm gonna pick up an item that you
don't want this one oh right here just
pick some do you like it like ah this is
hard to just do the ones that are it's
like um cards manatee whenever we play
cards against humanity' by the way we
have a rule that you're allowed to
endlessly discard because we don't want
to play the like throwaway round so we
want every round to be [ __ ] dope we
actually we got to the point where you
got that big expansion and we took out
all the unfunny or like boring ones yeah
we have like a super PAC with all the
bad ones removed it's pretty dope that's
what you should do at this game okay you
are a sorority girl you're a freshman in
college no no no you are a freshman that
means I'm rushing this sorority then
they didn't accept me if I'm a freshman
no you rushed the first semester you're
accepted the second semester right I'm a
second semester freshman aka a freshman
in college you're just getting your
bearings yeah Kenny is awful cute but he
hasn't looked at you in a while [ __ ]
okay you have a crush on him uh-huh
do you not yeah Kenny yeah the guy with
the the weird back guy I find that
endearing he likes you you just don't
know it yet uh-huh because when he looks
at you and he sees your sorority
sweatshirt and he looks up and he sees
it's you he's not sold yet yeah but
you're shy yeah yeah I get that yeah you
know some of your sisters can run around
and grab all the men they need plucking
them out of the school like flowers in a
garden you can't do that you're busy
with your studies
studies yeah go study right now we'll
finish this later
all right I'll talk to you later now
that we've gotten that far where are you
leaving why are you going you're busy
with your [ __ ] is what I'm saying okay
wouldn't it be nice if you could just
live your normal life attend to your
normal responsibilities as a college
freshman in a sorority and also be
spitting game all the while yes you want
to be spitting game but it's a lot of
energy and time to spit game yeah you
got the bot you gotta buy the magic sets
you gotta do the different things the
pre-production of all the different
stunts and pranks you're gonna pull on
your loved ones that you think that they
man maybe it'll like you after you do
all of what normal people do to attract
their mate until now we have a solution
it is banned by 99 universities united
states accepted by three so far and
yours just happens to be one of them
that's it's banned by but we're also
having this where is no one knows we're
talking okay it's invisible except for
the guy you want can he sees it can you
see it is a desire mask you put it on
your face and anyone who you love will
immediately reciprocate those feelings
the moment he lays eyes on your
invisible desire mask patent-pending we
were on shark tanks audition that they
kicked us out right away as seen on the
audition room kicked out of shark tank
okay it's form-fitted to your face okay
all you have to do is we send you this
pack okay it's got like putty in it you
slam your face into the putty hold your
face sometimes you suffocate we've had
three people die but it's we've looked
into it then you send back it hardens
this clay
it's an incredibly incredibly delicate
item so it breaks 9 out of 10 times on
the way back to us yeah on the on the
chance that it comes back in one piece
we take a picture of it with our iPhone
and then we draw our best version of it
into a mask
and then you just put it on and he loves
you
wow it is like something is it then
no it's thick oh it's very
very this the three C's I can't breathe
through it it no no it's you hold your
breath you know it's only when you're
seeing him so if you know you're gonna
cross pass through certain part of the
day you just pop up then he loves you he
desires they take it off well once the
desiring has been done he never saw the
mask it's it's it's again patent-pending
we're in the middle of a lawsuit but
well basically the FBI they're basically
getting turned into the FBI but before
we do hold on I okay it releases it
releases pheromones pheromones into the
air but very specific all you have to do
is get a piece of his DNA I'm saying you
need his DNA first yeah maybe just like
a piece of his yeah whatever piece of
skin or just like fish hook him and grab
some of his saliva all things that you
do in college I'm sure right yeah I know
yeah what's called okay so once you have
a DNA you pop it on you hold your breath
for a little bit hope to god it fits
because there are literally no refunds I
don't even have an office
it just shows up and and then you know
you take it off he loves you and then
you live happily ever after and if he
doesn't then you you won't be able to
find us we've been shut down by the FBI
I don't know how I got here I'm honestly
scared can I sleep no okay sleep like in
the in the break room in your dorm or
though yeah fun room yeah yeah we have
like a study room who's your RA care
that I'm sleeping there we won't we
don't tell it right I mean maybe I could
just wear a desire mask for her and then
she'll just she won't care at all I mean
it sounds it sounds a little weird but I
mean do what you want yeah yeah I mean
but the end of the day like I heard
about Kenny and I had to come here come
down here and tell you about this how
did you hear about kids you wanna invest
in this idea we haven't even started
anything yet
I don't have it I need no sorority girl
I just need your investment I don't have
any money no I just just sign here I
know I don't have a number when you went
to the fitness center with your girls
earlier this morning
yeah that sign is she was the contract
we now have your investment your desire
mask will be shipping early 20 can you
tell me why you're wanted by the FBI
I can't legally I cannot why is that
well because if I tell you you might be
wanted too oh okay but we're just
talking I have nothing into I went to
try to sell all of them the desire mask
they didn't like it
I'm on their list did you want them to
desire you no I want I want you to
desire them didn't work I tried to shove
it on their face they kicked me out
before I could get it done I'm scared
every night is just as pure worried so
in theory you could throw it on
someone's face and then you'll be in
love with them yes it's a way of
manipulating your own feelings or other
people's it sounds [ __ ] up yeah I know
it's it's horrible I've made a bad
change in the world yeah
I'm not proud of it but do you want to
buy we have a deal we have a deal thank
you sir I can't wait to maybe suffocate
myself I'm a girl thank you sir doing
business with you tell the rest of your
sorority sisters if they're if they're
interested they will also be wanted by
the FBI but to give them my am okay they
can reach me there
yes omegle is my primary preferred form
of communication oh my girl please tell
them to text me on omegle yeah yeah do
this log on and choose random chat and
join yeah I'll be there it's all fine is
that your face or your dick done well
it's my face
but that's an interesting business idea
I don't know maybe I'll consider let's
see on omegle okay okay let's bookmark
on my browser I'm inventing an app for
omegle it's basically just a mingle on
your phone okay
except it's it's a zero instead of an O
so it's our own app now we took all
their software uh-huh so you just match
two people randomly on your phone mm-hmm
this is a same amount of diff maked
people yes also they know where your
location is every time you match with
them that sounds scary omegle zero Magel
because there's zero safety involved
Cheers
welcome to the company so sick we just
hold this morning well done good good
stuff [ __ ] fun this game is really
fun it really is I I personally I know
how like off off we are and how you're
supposed to play it but like I think
it's fun to play it like we weren't fun
to play it like this can you imagine
though if we had like we always play
just you and me if you played with more
people yeah we should like Busta sounds
like a drinking game and be fun that
would be fun cuz you're full of [ __ ]
like months that was no fun a [ __ ] show
because you're actually full of [ __ ] I'm
actually a [ __ ] I'm I've been called the
[ __ ] meter before Shh Julian [ __ ] meter
no just [ __ ] Meetup
that's terrible you know you know who
you are okay
it was Ron and Ashley they caught me
[ __ ] Mena
cuz I was being a [ __ ] well I believe
that I believe you're being [ __ ] I still
think my last name should stay out of it
we'll see who wins next round all right
well guys think generally one i didn't
do as well this time no I think you did
I think you did well I just you're
talking to the greatest in all of you
know I feel like people did this game we
should have play with us Jeff yeah Jeff
we need to have Jeff be like a regular
on the podcast or something yeah like
just a segment oh yeah cuz the first
rows you guys that watch the twitch
stream himself we play this Jeff all the
time he's hysterical but like the first
podcast we had him on that was like you
know the second time we had met him when
we sort of just yeah we like barely knew
him and we it was like so interviewed it
well it was so stiff like we didn't we
weren't friends yet like you said so
like well obviously it was a completely
different like now when we play we play
with them all time we shoot the [ __ ] and
stuff and I think I think that would be
it would be cool to like think of a fun
way to implement him on a semi-regular
basis but thank you guys for watching
sad no no no no thank you guys for
watching the podcast on snake oil part 2
we hope you enjoyed it
let us know in the comments if you guys
want to pitch us some of your snake oil
inventions cuz we are here to buy we are
in the market thanks again
we're Shark Tank Wanaka we're snake tank
this has been another episode of shark
tank with this is shark addicting this
is the snake pit we have we took over
snakes channel this is we are twitter
thanks guys have a wonderful week and
we'll see you next one next one we'll
see you next one
you
[Music]